a lie gets halfway around the world
before the truth has a chance to get his
pants on why we have such an easier time
buying rumors and gossip and buying it
to someone's victim with mentality then
we do a leader who's challenged you to
change to improve and go out into
something big in your life you're gonna
come across a leader that's going to
tell you can do it you should go for it
I think and pull this off it's gonna be
painful once you give it a shot what if
it does take place what if you go out
there make a difference what if you do
live your dreams what if you go against
all the odds wouldn't you prove
everybody wrong in your life that's that
you can do it it'll be on you to tell
the tool part